Прорив для німецьких правопопулістів.
Час їхнього тріумфу, а також сигнал
усьому континенту: правий популізм живий
і почувається в Європі добре.
Це попереджувальний сигнал  для німецької
політики про те, що люди хочуть іншого.
Вони не сприймають міграційної політики
Анґели Меркель, як вона собі це уявляла.
Справді, останні два десятиліття правопопулістські
партії в країнах Європейського союзу на підйомі.
Їхня популярність росла на тлі останніх
економічних криз, і ось результат – вони
потрапили до парламентів вже 20-ти країн-членів ЄС.
Анти-мігрантські, анти-ісламські, анти-європейські:
по усьому континенту популісти використовують
страх та гнів невдоволених виборців.
Раніше цього року третина французьких виборців
захотіли, щоб Марін Ле Пен, лідерка
праворадикального Національного  Фронту
стала новим президентом.
А за три тижні до виборів у Австрії популярність
націоналістичної Партії Свободи сягає 25 %.
Наша мета – залишитися господарями
у нашій власній країні.
Хай щастить, ми починаємо,
в нашої Батьківщини є надія!
Активізація популістів винесла їхні анти-європейські,
анти-мігрантські гасла на передову політики ЄС.
Той, хто каже, що в Європі чи конкретно в Німеччині
настав момент повторювати гасла правих популістів,
той глибоко помиляється і наражає
Європу на велику небезпеку.
Тепер Бундестаг став для "Альтернативи для Німеччини"
найвищою трибуною, яку ця партія мала
за всю свою недовгу історію.
При чому йдеться про одну з найбільш
потужних країн Європи.
Це виклик і для нового німецького
уряду, і для Європи.